ALICIA WILLIAMS: Cloud Spanner
is a relational database
that powers billion-user products every month
It's trusted by
banks, retailers,
and many other
organizations to support
their mission-critical
applications.
So how do you know if
Spanner makes sense for you?
Today, we're highlighting
three industries
that rely on Spanner to
solve challenges, reduce
costs, and accelerate
innovation to deliver best
of breed customer experience.
Stay tuned.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
In our last episode, we covered
why Spanner is a great option
to hit the optimal balance
between scalability,
consistency, and high
availability for your database.
In this episode, we're
going to connect the dots
to show you how Spanner is being
used to solve pressing problems
in financial services,
retail, and gaming.
First up, financial services.
Banks, fintech companies,
and their regulators
demand 24/7 access to
accurate information
in order to drive
core operations.
They use Spanner in a wide
range of applications,
including payment gateways
and online banking.
Payment gateways
connect purchases
from many, often
millions of customers
to thousands of vendors.
The scale alone can make
typical databases buckle.
Compounding the problem,
all of this data
needs to be 100%
consistent as payments flow
through sophisticated anti-fraud
and settlement processes.
Dropping a payment
or double counting
would be a serious issue.
Spanner is also used
today in online banking
to improve reliability
and enable innovation
for mission-critical processes,
such as transaction tracking
and user profile management.
Customer demands
for new products
and modern interactive
experiences
have taxed online
banks' databases.
With last generation
scale-up technologies,
banks had to rearchitect
their systems
to scale in ways their
databases weren't designed for.
The result is extra
complexity and maintenance.
Developers have to work around
a fragmented view of the data,
while operators struggle
to ensure uptime
in a stitched together system.
Banks and fintech
innovators choose
Spanner because of its
industry-leading five
nines of availability, zero plan
maintenance downtime, security
certifications, and the
highest consistency guarantees
of any scale-out database.
Spanner allows
financial services
to scale their
databases regionally
or even globally without
any downtime or compromises
to the integrity or
security of their data.
This scale insurance
means they're
able to easily accommodate
long-term growth
or unexpected spikes without
painful rearchitecture
or downtime.
Spanner eliminates complexity
and maintenance overhead
by pushing sharding
and replication down
into the database, not
as an afterthought.
To your developers
and DBAs, it looks
like a single database instance
that can scale on-demand.
Spanner is also used in
the red hot gaming industry
to support real-time gameplay
and in-game purchases that
are driving revenues.
Popular game launches have
become cultural touchstones.
Even a niche game can attract
millions of global users
at launch who demand interactive
gameplay that's always online.
This burst of high
volume real-time traffic
can be game over for
common databases.
Ensuring play from
a gamer in Asia
is immediately visible
to her opponent
in South America typically
requires manual database
sharding in order to scale.
In modern digital games,
database maintenance windows
are also a big risk.
With global players and
multiple game franchises,
it can be impossible
to schedule downtime
to patch the database
or updated schema
to support new capabilities.
For gaming or any other
always-on global business,
Spanner is fully
managed and never
needs to be paused for
patches, backups, failover,
or even schema updates.
Using Google's dedicated
infrastructure,
Spanner guarantees consistency
and zero plan downtime,
even at the most
extreme scale, which
translates into better gameplay
and satisfied customers.
Retailers face many of the same
challenges as banks and game
studios.
New digital channels,
like online shopping
with in-store pickup, digital
wallet, and mobile rewards
redemption present
new opportunities,
but also impose additional
hurdles for already stretched
IT organizations.
Retail supply chains
have also become
more complex and on-demand.
Just in time fulfillment and
dynamic pricing and e-commerce
mean that a retailer's inventory
and product catalog must always
be up to date and consistent.
Stock-outs erode
trust from consumers
whose alternative purchasing
options are on the rise.
Spanner gives retailers
a consistent view
of their inventory, pricing,
and demand across channels
and locations without having
to hack together data stores
and using the SQL that
developers and analysts already
know.
Online orders are immediately
reflected in inventory
across online and brick and
mortar stores and warehouses,
across thousands of products
and hundreds of locations.
If this weren't
challenging enough,
retail often experiences
extreme seasonal spikes,
like during Black Friday.
In the past, retailers
overprovisioned hardware
to handle holiday peaks,
but this is increasingly
expensive and inefficient.
Scaling on last
generation's databases
requires large upfront
expenses and downtime.
New SQL technologies
claim web scale
but don't generally support
the transactions or SQL
that developers rely on.
Spanner gives retailers
the confidence
that they'll be able
to handle peak periods
without large upfront costs
or maintenance overhead.
Elastic scaling allows them to
expand regionally or globally
in a single click.
Later, they can scale back down,
paying for only what they use,
without missing a beat.
So there you have it, a dip into
the benefits of availability,
consistency, and scalability in
fin serve, gaming, and retail.
High availability means you get
an industry-leading five nines
uptime and never have to work
around plan maintenance again.
Get the strictest level of
consistency of any distributed
database without
sacrificing scalability
for operational workloads.
And scale out and
back in as needed
to avoid costly excess
capacity while handling
unpredictability.
This video is just a sampling
of the many industries and use
cases where Spanner helps
companies solve problems
and grow their business.
So if you're curious
to learn more,
follow the links
in the description
below for additional
information.
Thanks for joining
us today and stay
tuned for more episodes of
Spanner, database unlimited.
[MUSIC PLAYING]